I've got some bad economic news this
past month September of 2017 we saw the
first net job losses in the United
States dating all the way back to the
year 2010 according to the latest
numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics there was a net loss of
33,000 jobs in September now the
Hurricanes in the south of the country
are partially to blame but the
expectations had already accounted for
the Hurricanes so the real number ended
up being even lower than the hurricane
adjusted expected numbers now I'm not
going to pretend I know that there are
people who when it's a Democratic
president they give all the praise for
jobs created to the president and when
it's a Republican president they
criticized that Republican president for
any job loss I'm not going to pretend
for a second that Donald Trump is the
singular cause of job losses the way I
didn't pretend that Barack Obama was
singularly responsible for gains and
jobs during his administration however
there are some real areas to look at
here right number one we know that
travel money coming into the United
States is down specifically because of
Donald Trump Donald Trump's presidency
as directly and single-handedly
decreased the amount of interest in
doing tourism in the United States and
to be totally honest with everybody here
there were some ok numbers as well in
this jobs report right and I know if I
don't mention them people will say I'm
hiding them the unemployment rate fell
to 4.2 percent in September of 2017
that's the lowest in 16 years of course
as you know when you stop looking for
work you're no longer listed as
unemployed that was a factor under Obama
it's a factor now as well restaurants
and bars were some of the hardest hit
industries by the September hurricanes
okay that makes sense but it isn't just
September back in July and August the
expected jobs numbers were also revised
down and you've got right-wingers using
math tricks to mess with people there
are some Republicans who are saying no
no no this was a really good jobs report
because wages are way up and this is
this is where you
to think critically okay Republicans say
restaurants and bars have seen job
losses because of the Hurricanes wages
are up bars and restaurants pay low
wages when those are the jobs that are
eliminated the average the mean wage
goes up without anybody actually getting
a raise so you have to understand how to
critically look at these numbers more
than likely jobs numbers will do pretty
well for the next few months one reason
why is that federal aid is going to be
used to rebuild after the Hurricanes
Trump will ignore the bad numbers this
month next month he'll tout the good
numbers even though supposedly
government isn't supposed to create jobs
except these are jobs created by
government federal aid so you've got to
really look hard to figure out all of
the I guess I'd call the mathematical
gymnastics that the right is doing
around the economy and also you should
be prepared for seasonally adjusted jobs
versus raw jobs numbers we're entering
the or October November yeah we're in
the fourth quarter of 2017 in the fourth
quarter you have retail businesses doing
a ton of temporary hiring so what you
need to look at is seasonally adjusted
jobs numbers but the real misdirection
to be aware of is the long list of
politicians who know nothing about
economics and are weighing in trying to
hype the Trump tax plan in response to
this job report in fact we have a quote
from congressman Kevin Brady a
Republican from Texas who said quote by
passing a budget that paves the way for
tax reform the house took a major step
yesterday towards creating more jobs
fairer taxes and bigger paychecks in the
weeks ahead the Ways and Means Committee
will move forward with pro-growth Pro
middle-class tax reform legislation that
Congress will ultimately send to the
President's desk this year for the first
time in 31 years so first and foremost
we analyzed the tax plan it does nothing
for the middle class but the bigger
picture is that it will do nothing for
hiring either and I know I sound like a
broken record at this
businesses don't hire because you reduce
the tax rate of the business owners
businesses will not hire if you reduce
the tax rate on rich people who won't
spend their newly found money anyway but
are more likely to save it and
businesses will not hire if you reduce
the business tax rate do not fall for it
and can you imagine pointing to the tax
plan it's something that's going to
create hiring our plan to cut the estate
tax for couples with more than eleven
eleven million dollars in assets is
going to be great for hiring of lower
and middle-class people what what and
you've got to understand just that the
basic level why the economics of that
make absolutely no sense and people on
our reddit discussion forum are talking
about this and I encourage you to join
us there david pakman.com slash re d di
t we'll take a break
former FBI special agent mark Ruskin
joins me next movement watches
sponsoring today's program love having
movement watches as a sponsor I have a
movement watch and I wear it all the
time people love it might at my
dentist's office you might be wondering
why might the dentist's so much that's a
topic for a different day but at my
dentist's office every time I go and
sign in I get a question about that's a
really good watch where did you get that
and I got it online and that's sort of
the great thing about the movement watch
business model which is by selling
directly online to over a hundred and
sixty countries by the way movement
watches cuts out the middleman so
instead of paying four or five hundred
dollars or more for this caliber and
this well-designed of a watch the
watches start at just $95 and not only
is this a company that has decided to
sell only online they're also similar to
the david pakman show and that they
crowdfunded to really launch the
business initially and it is a really
really cool set of watches and
sunglasses which are also available
through movement and you can save
fifteen percent if you go to MVM t.com
slash Pakman if you go to MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman you'll save fifteen percent
off of your watch you will get free
shipping you'll also get free return
MVM t-dot-com slash Pakman joined the
movement